はいどうもー
今回はこちらの赤い車がございます
駐車ミスで
線からちょっとはみ出て止めちゃったんですよ
こりゃ迷惑だ
すごい迷惑な時
いちいちエンジンをかけて
テツヤ：違う違う違うｗ
エンジンをかけて前進してまたバックして戻すのは非常に面倒臭いので
テツヤ：環境に悪いしね
はじめ：環境に悪い
はじめ：やっぱエコにしたい訳ですよ
エコにしたい
というわけで今回ですね
この車を自力で
前後ろは多分いけるんですよ
前後ろは行けるけど
横の
車を横にシフト
テツヤ：タイヤを超えた動きをね俺らでね
タイヤをこっち側に動かし
あの
人間の力でやろうと思います
ではいこう
いくぞぉ！
っしゃ
一人目
はじめ：一人目
いけー
はじめ：もう一人で
やったれやったれ
ではいきます
いけ、はじめー
テツヤ：全然動いてねぇぞ
全然動いてない
テツヤ：何やってんだ
テツヤ：おい、”ドンっ”ってやんなドンって
台パン
テツヤ：おい、やめろ
テツヤ：俺のお母さんの車だぞ
テツヤ：動いてないぞ～もやし～
はじめ：あああああ
はじめ：無理だ
二人ならいけると思う
テツヤ：なんかすげーパワーありそう
h:二人目いきます
T:おいおい、いけいけ
T:駐車して駐車してー
T:ガンっていったガンっていった！
T:俺のお母さんの
T:もやし、もやし、TシャツダサいぞTシャツ
T:Tシャツがダサいぞ
T:あ！バコンっていった、ねーー
T:取れ..え、え、え、待って待って
3人くらいやったらいけるでしょ
3人だったら H:いけるでしょ、3人だったら
お願いします
じゃあいくぞ！
H:よーいスタート
いったれ
T:おーい、もう！
T:お母さんの車、クソぉ
T:絶対怒られる
T:絶対怒られるよー
H:ダメだ
H:4人いきましょう
4人いきますか
T:もうちょっとな感じはしました
もうちょっとで別の意味で終われる（壊れる？）
終われる（壊れる？）
はじめ：最後は4人で
ラストチャンス
はじめ：ラストチャンスです
H:これでダメならもうエンジンかけます
H:環境には悪いけど
せーの
T:お、いけそう
T:あ、おっ、本当に動いてる
T:え！？
H:タイヤが
T:すげー
H:いけるぞ
T:いけ、いけ、頼む
H:じゃあ、前を攻めます
前を攻めます
せーの
ああああ！
じゃあ、ラストはこの
いかにも持ち上げてくださいと言わんばかりの
T:完全にそのため
H:これをもう4人でやります
T:すごい頑丈だしね
いけるっしょ
せーの
ええええい
アアアア！！！！
～＾ED＾～